CREATING A TWO ON ONE DOWN LOW,T
GET THROUGI'M ALWAYS
LOOKING TO GET FANCY WITH IT
ON THE MOVE HERE 2-1, DEBRINCA
WRITIN IT AROUND THEN TW
DEVELOPMENT.
HATHAWAY ON THE CROS
HATHAWAY AND TO HAGELIN ANA FOUW
BECAUSE THEY WERE ALL TRAPPED.
THAT IS QUITWAY TO THE THREE OVT
SETBACK ON THE WORLD JUNIORS
JUST A LITTLE BIT K LIKE AE AGAN
WHAT A SHOCK
HE'SH THAT CHRONIC
INFLAMMATORY RESPONSE SYNDROME
>> OVECHKIKI A PAST GREAT ONCE E
EXTENDE THREE GOAL
FOR THE WASHINGTON CAPITALS.
E BS
WASHINGTON
IT'SS NOT A BAD HOCKEY
GOALIE
YOU SEE IT FROM TIME TO TI, SHOH
24-21.
IN FAVOR OF WASHINGTON
BESE WILL GO UP
>> NOW WATCH FOR OVECHKI OVERLAR
TOM WILSON WHO HAS T
THIS WILL BOUNCE HURRY
KIRBY DACH A 20-YEAR-OLD
BUILDING U SECONDS
TO OPERATE IN OVERTIME
WILSON, THE PASSE SKILLS
COMPETITION HERE IN TH
SHOOTOUT
>> SOME OFHAN TOEWS IN THE BOTTO
OF THE FIRST
50E YOU WANT TO PLAC
IT RIGHT OVER THE LEFT PAD AND
THERLD BE IN THE
HALL OF FAME